NFC East Cowboys are now five and four
Eagles are five and four Cowboys won the
head-to-head matchup they play again
later this year in Philadelphia that
one's coming up at week 16 but between
now and then look at what the Cowboys
have the Cowboys go to Detroit this
weekend yeah
not any now they may not get Matthew
Stafford which will help yeah still not
an easy place to play then they go to
New England yeah then they got the bills
on Thanksgiving that is not gonna be an
easy no it won't and they go to Chicago
yeah I don't care I don't care how good
or bad the Bears are going to Soldier
Field in December not an easy game then
the Rams come to town we saw what the
Rams did Cowboys was it last year the
year before when they went to Dallas I
mean last year two years later high off
the five years ago in Dallas when they
destroy or to wrest roid right then it's
at Philly week 16 the schedule really
doesn't soften until the last game of
the season when they host Washington the
Eagles on the other hand now the Eagles
host New England yes have a lot better
than going to indefinitely host Seattle
they go to Miami they play the Giants
there at Washington so they got some
they got for their final five games or
winnable because they still play the
Giants twice down the stretch and the
Giants feel like they're falling apart
right now I think the Eagles gonna win
that division I didn't Cowboys may miss
the playoffs in a famous last night's
game could be the difference between
Jason Garrett remaining employed as the
Cowboys coach and not remaining employed
because I think after last night's game
there is a very real chance they don't
make the playoffs that's that's scary I
mean it you know what you're getting
scared of with teams like you know the
Eagles and the Cowboys you know you
can't in your on you you almost have to
win the division but I I'm with you Mike
I have more confidence in the Eagles and
even though like Dallas answered the
bell last year I know I get that and
they went on a run and they're still
capable of that my big thing is I think
hey the Dallas Cowboys their offense is
better than most years it really is
Ezekiel Elliott and the run game is not
as explosive that concerns me but the
overall offense is as good as it's been
maybe since Tony Romo in his prime my
big thing is the defensive side of the
ball and there is not enough game plan
specific game planning by the defense in
Dallas where I look at Philadelphia and
they're just getting health
they're starting to run the ball on
offense and their corners are back
playing good you know Fletcher Cox is
finally a hundred percent and then Jim
Schwartz does crazy crap you know
sometimes it bites him in the butt but
he is creative and he thinks outside the
box and he's not gonna just you know sit
there and go oh I'm gonna let this is my
defenses this is what I do and we're
just gonna hustle and play sound you
know that's all cool and dandy against
like the lower middle class and lower
class in the NFL you can get away with
that when you're a team like Dallas or
Philadelphia but if you want to be teams
like the Patriots so the 49ers are the
upper class teams you can't just go this
is what we do and this is what we're
gonna do and we know you know what we're
gonna do and this is just we're gonna
execute no it's just not gonna happen
I'm sorry and you know we've seen it
again Dallas and their losses when it's
a decent offensive system and a
quarterback who can move a little bit
and they have a weapon or they can't
overcome it as talent as they are and
they're as talented as any defense in
football they can't overcome it because
their scheme never gives them help and
why don't they change it I don't know
it's amazing it is and it all goes back
to Jason Garrett and look the Cowboys
have stubbornly stuck with Jason Garrett
for a variety of reasons I think Jerry
Jones has some pride in that he's
developed and he was patient with Jason
Garrett and now he's getting the payoff
and also Jason Garrett's not gonna try
to take any of the spotlight away from
Jerry Jones Jerry Jones recently
insisted Jason Garrett's not a yes-man I
don't know that that's the issue the
issue is Jason Garrett never tries to
take over and lets the Joneses be the
center of the Cowboys universe and
that's the way they like it I just I
think right now when you look at the
schedule to look away the Eagles already
look at where the Cowboys are I think
the Eagles win that division and there's
a good chance the Cowboys don't make it
to the playoffs at all
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports